[Music]
and sharing is caring news submitted by
how you do you present it just some bad
away I'm always trying to be the man
right here I love it you're holding a
weight restrict a it's right yeah
because you don't want to be holding
winter astray submitted by my beaten by
my neck my back my neck my my my crack
oh wow
a sturdy says that the central practice
of cuckolding can be positive for some
couples holding holding that's like a
cheating so cook holding is when you
watch your partner have sex with it
someone else Oh usually guys watch their
wives or their girls gotcha
so they're observing it I'm ok with that
or someone who's getting he's cheated on
yeah you're a couple yeah oh you're
getting cheated I see ok why you have
been cheated on your cuckold uh yeah no
that's exactly what it is that's one and
then the another thing is like they
actually enjoy seeing their partner with
someone else
different strokes for different so
people if people are separated or for
whatever reason right without the
cheating you're divorced you know
divorcee but I'm a divorcee but if you
got cheated on and that's why it's your
cuckold you gotta hold it I saw this one
porno that like there was this yeah I
think it's like a pretty big John right
now we're like it's like the boyfriend
and girlfriend like oh we can't pay the
bills what are we gonna do and in like
the landlord comes and they're like hey
would you take my girlfriend's [ __ ] the
girlfriend but he's still jacking off
and he's crying in the corner checking
on it's like bad acting crying I would
legit and I don't care what happens to
my acting career anything at any point
of my acting career
I would legit be in a coupling porno as
the guy who's like did you have to do
anything yeah you don't do [ __ ] you said
I go
yeah you just don't do anything you just
watch live porn damn right so on your
IMDB you're the cuckolding crowd love it
I would love nothing more was the
youtuber that was on a porn thing and
Sally yeah there you go oh yeah I
couldn't get it up gonna get it up in
the game didn't get it up very famously
couldn't give it up very famously what
it's like a home bangbus yep who's not
bang bus you couldn't get it up was too
nervous I think probably cuz you know I
don't think I'd be able to get a hard-on
porno not intimate enough none of campus
well thank you for that the fluffer does
anything and I just got stage fright I'm
pretty sure they give you pills to help
you with that I'm not that kind of guy I
am the kind of guy that'd be out of
portal set but not the kind of guy that
those yeah to perform my job you got to
take a no pill no I like it that Oh
that's around no rat and that'll take no
pills right so according to a recent
study they're saying that acting on coke
holding fantasies can be a largely
positive experience for many couples who
the [ __ ] wrote this I mean are these
couples in their sixties because it
might make sense if you're like 60
something and you're like I want to
spice up my life is it the cat who who
wants to [ __ ] his friend's wife or is it
the cat who wants to feel okay about how
he likes this it's the cat that wants to
[ __ ] is here their scientific this is
not science I can't wait to hear what
the science is if I could just tickle my
fancy all right let me hear this is that
an actual friend I don't know I'll watch
I'll watch you get your phantom tickle
here let me just watch you get your
tickle fancy turn and I've never heard
of Mexicans say that ever hey tickle my
fancy a [ __ ] okay
shut up it's usually dumped at the back
of my truck that's more that's more
Mexican yes so they're saying that out
of the thousands of Americans that were
surveyed they found that 50% of men and
about a third of women
had fantasize about Coco Lee 35 percent
of women a third Oh a third of course
it's more men than women of course I
wonder if it's if it's a fetish that you
develop over time like wine have you
ever had a dream that you're part have
you been doing have you ever had a dream
that your partner was having sex with
somebody else no no I have recently you
like that I was very easy
did you [ __ ] dream cheater you don't
wants to [ __ ] so there's one of those
dreams but it's not you you're observing
you you know like an outside person yeah
and you have no control what's going on
but the fucked-up thing about the dream
wasn't the fact that it was like a
swinger type of thing it was the fact
that the partners that we were swinging
with were two of the ugliest [ __ ]
people on earth I was thoroughly upset
my dream I was supposed to but this what
happened right
so the first first is this it's it was I
had this really old redhead she looks
shriveled as [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this
stupid ass [ __ ] deal then I look at
the guy that she's gonna be with am I
even in your dream you get cock-blocked
could this old lady [ __ ] up no I
didn't get to that part I was already
pissed off at the fact that this lady
was like 80 years old any walk up you
would have been down well I couldn't
control cuz it wasn't me it was me
watching this whole thing go down and
then my me was like what the [ __ ] like
clearly upset do not get so [ __ ] late
in my dreams it's crazy I kill my dreams
I sleep Izumo do you wake up with wet
with wet dreams oh dude I mean no I
don't wake up physically with wet dreams
but I got everything else in my dream I
think like most of my dreams I'm just
like in space eating that [ __ ] space
man ice cream and the [ __ ] bag and
[ __ ] you're in space eating space food
you know the space ice cream in the it's
like horse dry yeah I don't really know
what it tastes like it's just fantasy
he's actually pretty you don't like it
oh I did it if you get the right one the
ice cream channel that's good oh yeah
yeah I like it
oh yeah I got shitty dreams man it's
just like swimming or parasailing or
something when is shitty
I want to have some dreams feel like I'm
on Mars and like I'm a dog you're almost
there you're in space gonna be a dog in
a dream yeah like a dog in space that
could breathe space air I begin having a
lot of murderous dreams lately where I'm
just [ __ ] killing the [ __ ] out of
your people I think it's because I've
been taking a melatonin to sleep and
that [ __ ] [ __ ] up your I don't know
like the trees are way too vivid I don't
like it melatonin melatonin like I don't
think like sleeping pills don't sleep
but damn did like they're pretty [ __ ]
vivid did like I'm [ __ ] slaughtering
people but not in like they're like good
human beings like it's my mission to
kill these people are you moving in slow
motion like a regular dream no these
aren't blasting the [ __ ] out of people
do that mean it's like me going into a
house and I know that there's like demon
possessed people and I'm like oh they're
all bad they're all evil oh yeah not bad
stuff but it's very weird because it's
usually like that but I can't commit all
the way through I get [ __ ] up every
dream I got getting into some [ __ ] I'm
throwing a punch and it's never like
this yeah yeah yeah well I'm kicking
people in the chest putting a [ __ ]
gun in their mouth Wow moving on to the
next one John wick [ __ ] yeah it's some
crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] can you punch oh I'm
shooting I'm not punching in this though
I'm just blasting people up every time I
run away it's like slow motion and it
catch up to me wonder why that happened
maybe that's something symbolic an
probably look up later that's not in
this article let's continue don't even
no one no [ __ ] pursuit of our dreams
like they just say they interpret it I
want that lucid dream [ __ ] where you can
control your reality yeah that's the
real shooter who said Oh Joey Joey go
fly I could fly that's it I can find you
yeah I got a jump like it's Super Mario
Brothers and in the Cape I'll put the
third one when you're the telekinetic
telekinesis whatever I have to look at
me cuz I can move things right lucky I
know and then I realize that I'm doing
it and then I I can't Howard and then
when you wake up you try to do it in
real life and the Casey catches you'll
cause your dumb ass it's just that dream
and then you wake up turn into the lucid
dreaming cuz lucid really you know that
you're dreaming you can control it and
but as soon as I know I'm dreaming I
wake up see if I was a lucid dream right
probably I live in this little world
right now exactly it's like VR but it's
better yeah cuz you don't know you're in
being I mean like if you don't know that
be someone it's like the avatar I want
telekinesis and said I just got crushed
[ __ ] the whole time so
you know if it's not telekinesis and I'm
dreaming about punching someone usually
Casey because you like do something oh
my god yeah did you can't hit the person
you love oh she's trying to I'm sure
she's trying her hardest to Casey's love
forcefield is too strong so it's holding
her fist back no you know it's weird
like before we got before the wedding I
kept having a lot of dreams and you know
how everybody say you dream because
you're working things out subconsciously
and I guess I was really anxious about
the wedding and so I was having a lot of
dreams of Casey either flirting with
other girls or like actually like
cheating on me with another girl and so
I would go up to them and like try to
beat their ass and I can't and I'm just
like oh and sewing because I can't punch
them I would scratch them and I try to
like tear their skin and was like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then I go to Casey
like you're [ __ ] [ __ ] Oh what kind
of [ __ ] got my for you or nothing cuz
I'm literally blasting people in the
face I trying to figure out that it's
pretty amazing though but it's also a
little creepy because you know they're
not real humans so like it's just like
they're coming out of every corner so I
got to figure out what the [ __ ] I'm
trying to do so it's kind of scary
because like I'm on the verge of death
well what's happening in your like
you're realizing he's just playing doom
all day it's weirdest thing I do I do
them all day I just been watching like
brickleberry and [ __ ] and then I haven't
been playing games I don't even know
where the [ __ ] this is coming from no
but like your work like like maybe
something's happening or your
relationship oh you're fighting with
your girlfriend
maybe that's it dude if your chick was
like hey I want you to watch me [ __ ]
some dude what are you doing I say
though I get the [ __ ] out of my life you
weird ugly you're not you're not being a
good good man you gotta listen to her
feelings and [ __ ] right go [ __ ] about
her feelings never in a million [ __ ]
years if she was like really like and
you're you're married now so like yo
this isn't gonna work done but if it's
another girl oh absolutely you should do
it
yeah because it's because I care about
your feelings so much what if she said
you watched someone [ __ ] me and I'll
watch you [ __ ] someone else I couldn't
do it man I'm too territorial I'm a
territorial piece of [ __ ] man as soon as
another
our dick enters the room my dick goes
limp doesn't make anyone you've been
begging for like anything like either me
with the girl or me with the dude or
some [ __ ] wait Casey wants you to do
what it do liar liar we're a boss cage
there's so many fans they're gonna be
like no he used to always like in the
early in the relationship he'd be like
come on like would you be down like [ __ ]
for a guy oh thank you very for a guy or
girl Casey seems like the kind of guy
that has two clamps on his nipples yeah
the kind of guy who would wear like a
[ __ ] bondage mask me [ __ ] and you
hit it with the webbing is he the kind
of guy that pictured Casey no I'm just
picturing that guy dressed in gold like
we wouldn't find it so bad if you
watched her get it on with another girl
that's true because there's no
penetration I explained this to summer
TV but if the girl has a strap-on it's
fine fingers no it doesn't town we don't
care we don't care we don't care it's
about it's about penetrate it's about
like physically invading my wife's
whatever what up that guy's dick is like
way smaller nurse that's fine
one of the pieces just like that's it
just don't want someone out doing you
that's it that's a hundred percent black
guys no way hey from what I heard no way
conventional wisdom sorry what if it's
really really thin but it's very low oh
my god disgusting I got her mama like a
really thin penis some guys like
watching this right now he's got like a
cup of noodle and he's got a he's got a
long thin dick and he's like I mean it's
for other women it's not just
it's not for us people out that love
your dick it's just not in this room
[Music]